said Academy low C they are taking up a
new obsession rescuing animals the
Animal Club there is rescuing a
successful first project a food drive
both teachers and kids there excited to
start their next fundraising project
seeing the kids get so involved is
really what just makes me just it makes
my heart so warm and I know it's not
just me but it's all of The Rescuers it
feels honestly great like I feel amazing
giving back to like shelters and letting
it's like letting me know like animals
are okay for that fundraiser the
students are choosing to donate 100 of
their proceeds to the Tommy cat
foundation and Heaven Can Wait
non-profits two great groups